nous restons sur le thème de la santé
tous les mois attrape des rencontres
sont organisées avec un médecin sur
justement le thème de la santé pour
discuter santé mardi dernier au centre
socioculturel annette moreau attrape a
eu lieu une après-midi des changes
autour de la santé de l'homme pendant
une après midi les participants ont pu
découvrir ou approfondir leurs
connaissances sur l'organe génital
masculin et son fonctionnement
un reportage signé william l c'est une
assistance exclusivement composée de
femmes qui écoutent attentivement le
docteur jacques segal parler d'eux
prostate d'érection ou d'andropause
l'objectif de cette rencontre autour de
la santé de l'homme expliqué au public
l'organe génital masculin et son
fonctionnement est long plus
d'informations sur l'anatomie de la
femme que sur l'anatomie de l'homme et
elles savent très peu de choses sur la
sexualité de l'homme et sur les
mécanismes qui permettent les rapports
sexuels pourtant ouverte à tous ces
rencontres accueillent généralement un
public féminin venu chercher des
informations utiles qui leur permettront
de mieux comprendre leur conjoint ou
leur enfant pour beaucoup de deux femmes
quelles que soient les cultures c'est
difficile de voir des images du sexe de
l'homme d'entendre parler de comment ça
fonctionne etc mais aussi on fait ça de
façon détendue et respectueuse et bien
n'a pas de réseau non plus de véhiculer
des tabous parce que ce sont des temps
le but du docteur segal faire tomber ses
tabous par la parole en expliquant même
certaines pathologies
au début des questions sont timides mais
toujours pertinente
un premier pas difficile mais
aujourd'hui c'est vénus qui l'a fait
vers mars